Facebook made approximately 1 million
dollar every minute and most of this
through Facebook advertising by slowly
lowering organic reach on Facebook pages
over the years businesses now understand
that to use Facebook successfully they
have to pay to play
unfortunately Facebook's advertising
offering is second to none in concept
different than Google ads but in
execution pretty much the same where
Google ads are intent based Facebook ads
are more about awareness and serving
people the right ads with the right
content during their buying journey
Facebook ad campaign structure ad
objectives and targeting well let's
start advertising on Facebook shall we
well it's easier said than done there
are many people who have dip their toe
in the advertising water but they don't
get out of it what they expect to get
why is that Facebook advertising seems
so simple well there may be various
reasons why they're not successful but
in general it comes down to a lack of
understanding of the different
components that play a role in digital
advertising whether it's Google ads or
Facebook Ads Facebook advertising can be
your formula 1 car but it comes down to
fine-tuning every component that makes
the car run so let's have a closer look
at some of the Facebook advertising
components here is some jargon that you
will come across when you advertise on
Facebook and many of these terms are
standard within the digital marketing
space I won't cover every one of them
but let's just highlight a few of the
important ones as you will see in this
lesson digital advertising is often
split into three components the campaign
the ad account and the ads for each ad
you will have to set an objective and
these objectives could be things like
conversions impressions mobile app
installs or clicks you also have to
decide which target audience you want to
reach you can create your custom
audience or
you could even create what we call a
look-alike audience you also need to
decide on the placement of your ads will
this be on the Facebook newsfeed the
mobile or within a video and finally you
need to decide on the budget of your
campaign so let's start with the basics
each Facebook ad implementation consists
of three components the campaign the ad
set and the ad itself the campaign can
have multiple ad sets but it only has
one objective in the ad sets you define
things like the targeting the budget the
schedule the price and the placement and
then within an ad set you can have
multiple ads which are the creative
posts that you want to promote when you
create an ad on Facebook you will be
guided through three stages of your ad
campaign and we will show this later the
first thing you will have to do when you
want to start advertising on Facebook is
to set up your ad campaign an important
part of this is to define your
advertising objective and Facebook will
guide you through this Facebook will
tailor the structure of your ads to the
objectives that you've set for example
if you select to promote your page as an
objective your ad will be optimized to
get more likes on your Facebook page you
will then be guided to create your ad
set it will tell Facebook how to run
your ads here you will decide on the
targeting you will look at things like
location gender or interest and you will
also set details of how much you want to
spend when you want to pay for an ad
placement and where you want to place
your ads and then finally you will
create your ads you can pick different
formats for your ads and you can add
images video text and call-to-action
buttons often people have multiple
versions of their ad in an ad set so
they can test which one performs best so
let's have a look at the different
objectives you can set for your ad
campaign they can be grouped in three
categories top of the funnel middle of
the funnel and
bottom of the funnel with the funnel we
mean the sales funnel which typically
goes from awareness to in stressed to
desire or consideration and to action or
conversion also known as the Ida formula
top of the funnel objectives aims to
generate awareness these ads will try to
give you the biggest reach and brand
awareness middle of the funnel
objectives aim at turning awareness into
interest or consideration these ads are
geared towards driving engagement and
traffic and can include things like app
installs or video views and finally
bottom of the funnel ads are geared
towards conversions where you can get
people to register to download to
purchase from your catalog or to visit
your store here are some ads that have
an awareness objective this is about
making people aware of your business or
show them the value you can offer them
targeting is an important aspect of
these ads you can go as far as showing
your ad to those people who are near
your local business here are two typical
consideration ads often these ads have a
goal to find new customers
these can be ads to get conversations
with people on Facebook messenger or
lead generation ads to get people to
sign up for your newsletter for example
finally some examples of conversion ads
who often are aimed at driving sales or
very specific actions like getting
people to use or to download your mobile
app the next thing I want to introduce
to you in a bit more detail is
Facebook's targeting that you can do
when you create your ad sets this is one
of the most powerful features of
Facebook advertising you can create
three types of audiences for your ads a
core audience a custom audience and a
look-alike audience so let's have a look
at these in a bit more detail core
audience targeting takes place when you
go through the standard ad creation
process in Facebook you can target
people based on demographics on location
interests or certain behaviors you can
create custom audiences as well you can
import your existing customers through
their email address Facebook will check
if they use this email for signing up at
Facebook and if they did they will add
them to your custom audience list or you
can target people who visited a certain
page on your website this is also called
retargeting or Facebook pixel
advertising we will talk about this in
great detail later in this training
finally you can also create custom
audiences based on mobile app usage type
of engagement or offline activity like
visiting your store finally Facebook can
create a look-alike audience for you it
will do this by taking an existing
audience and then find people who share
similar characteristics in a different
location for example this is a great way
to expand your reach for Facebook Ads
Facebook Ads placements ad formats and
budgeting so there are two areas where
you can advertise on Facebook Instagram
or messenger or off Facebook on the so
called
audience network there is a wide variety
of options when it comes to placements
for your ads on facebook by default
Facebook will manage the placements it
will optimize this in such a way that
you can get the biggest return on your
advertising spent but if you feel
confident you can plan your own
placements for the audience network you
can also leave that up to Facebook you
just specify the categories and the
interests but again if you want to you
can even specify the websites yourself
the Facebook audience network consists
of thousands of websites and mobile apps
where Facebook will place your ads this
can give a much wider coverage of your
ads advertising on the audience network
works very well for retargeting ads now
that you've selected where you're going
to place your ads you're going to think
about how much you will spend on your ad
campaign and when you want to run the
campaign the budget module will do two
things for you you will plan your
overall spent on the campaign and how
much you want to bid for an ad placement
Facebook decides on when to place your
ads based on various things like quality
of the ads consistency with the landing
page but also based on the bit you put
in for the ads the bidding is a process
where Facebook looks at all the ads that
are competing for a position it done
looks at the highest bidder and they
will get the first option to place the
ads this all happens in nanoseconds and
we will talk more about this later and
once you've agreed your budget you are
going to schedule your ads again you can
leave it up to Facebook as long as you
give Facebook a start and an end date or
you can decide yourself when to show
your ads this allows you to schedule
your ads around the online habits of
your target audience bear in mind that
Facebook will not start your campaign
until it has approved your ad in the
digital marketing world there are in
general two ways you pay for your online
ads they are known as PPC and PPI PPC
stands for pay-per-click PPI stands for
paper impression the name says it all as
long as you understand the basics with
PPC
you don't pay for showing the ads you
pay once somebody clicks on the
call-to-action button PPC gives you the
extra benefit of free awareness but PPC
is more expensive than the other type
PPI with PPI you pay per impression
often per 1,000 impressions so you pay
for every time the ad is presented on
somebody's feed story or video but
remember this doesn't necessarily mean
that they have seen the ad now let's
look at the ad creation there are
various ways you can create your ads if
you are experienced in using Facebook
ads you can go to the quick creation
mode you decide on what stage of the
creation process you want to work on if
you're a beginner you can use the guided
creation in the guided creation Facebook
will guide you through each face step by
step you can of course create multiple
ad sets within your campaign and you can
even upload your campaign ad set and add
data through an excel file this is
particularly handy if you manage a lot
of ads there are many types of ads
without going into too much detail here
we will do this later there are some ads
you need to be aware of there are lead
ads dynamic ads and linked ads lead ads
are only for mobile and I'll allow you
to add a data capture form so you can
get people's info dynamic ads are put
together based on somebody's behavior so
when somebody visits your product page
you can retarget that person with a
dynamic ads showing the product they saw
in your website and there are linked ads
ads that drive people to your website
for instance here are some other ad
formats
image ads and video ads they speak for
themselves make sure your images fit
both desktop and mobile and don't forget
the text in these ads still very
important also think about your video
programming to show multiple pictures in
your ads you can use slide show ads or
carousel ads slide show ads put a photo
or videos in a slideshow you add text
and the sound and off you go
carousel ads allow you to rotate ten
photos or videos within your ads and the
power of these ads is that each photo in
the carousel can have its own link
collection ads allow you to showcase
products from your catalog and the
instant experience ads is an ad
specifically for mobile devices the
benefit is that you can link a mobile
landing page to your ads to enhance the
branding experience and finally there
are ads specifically for messenger these
are great to drive people from messenger
to your website Facebook ad performance
testing and tools once face
that's approved her ads and more about
it later it will start running as per
the schedule and budget that you've set
with an ad manager you can see the
detailed results of your ads you will
see how many people saw your ads how
many people clicked on it and how much
you've spent on the campaign so far you
can see the results at a campaign level
ad set level and ad level when the ad
runs and you see the first results
coming in it is important to constantly
check the results and see if you need to
make some adjustments to the campaign
settings Facebook will decide on the
placement schedule based on your
settings but remember you can always
make adjustments yourself to summarize
the elements that you can change that
can impact the performance you can
fine-tune the target audience you can
fine-tune the ads or you can change the
bed let's expand a bit on fine-tuning
your ads it's a common practice in
digital marketing to test and experiment
with your ads to find the ad that will
give you the best performance we call
this split testing or a/b testing it's a
process of creating multiple versions of
your ads with slight variations
variations in the text in the image the
color or the call to action you then run
each ad for a certain period and then
you check which ad gives you the best
results in the campaign settings you can
select a be testing for your ads so
Facebook will do the process for you you
can also look at what we call
attribution typically the value of an ad
is determined at the last stage of the
sales cycle when people buy but there
are more stages when people click when
people add info when people put a
property in the shopping basket when
people go to the checkout and so on with
attribution you put a value to each step
and in doing that you can truly measure
the effectiveness of your campaign
Facebook has options for attribution and
we will cover that later
Facebook also has a tool called test and
learn
it's a tool that will help you in
testing and analyzing your campaign by
asking you a set of questions about your
campaign when your ad campaign is
completed you need to pay Facebook they
accept many standard payment methods now
you also understand why you need a
personal Facebook account to create your
Facebook page because the person who
owns the personal Facebook account
usually is also the one who owns the
credit card or bank account to pay if
you spend a lot of advertising with
Facebook like more than ten thousand
dollars per month you can pay through
monthly invoicing to help you in each
stage of the advertising creation
process Facebook has lots of tools
available creating your Facebook Ads
in the early years of Facebook their
revenue came from flyers these were
purchased by students or small local
businesses who paid anywhere between ten
to forty dollar per day to target an ads
to a specific college campus much has
changed since then Facebook is now one
of the dominant online advertising
companies on the Internet one of your
key differentiators is how they have
been able to translate user requirements
into a simple user interface this is all
about design structure and usability of
course Facebook at Google Ads as a
reference but they were able to turn a
complex process into a very simple
process Facebook ad manager the Facebook
ad interface is very easy to understand
it is built around the three elements of
your ad campaign the campaign the ad set
and the ads you can either choose for
quick creation or for guided creation in
the campaign section you set the
objectives in the ad section you decide
on audience placement budget and
schedule and in the ad section you
decide on the format the media and the
creative of your ad if you click on the
hamburger icon on the top left it will
take you to the ads manager menu this is
where you have access to many additional
tools you need for your ad campaign some
of the important ones that you will be
using
our audience insights creative hub ads
manager ad reporting and analytics and
audiences to create a Facebook ad
campaign you go from your Facebook page
on the top right and you click on the
create ad and as mentioned earlier here
you will see the three steps that you
need to go through in creating your
Facebook ad this first step is creating
your campaign the second step is
creating your ad set and the third step
is creating your ad now in your campaign
settings you look at things like your
campaign objectives the name of the
campaign and if you want to run test for
the campaign in your ad set creation you
select the audience the placement you
look at your budget and when you want to
run the campaign and in your ad creation
you look at the format the identity and
the media that you're using in your
campaign so let's look at the objectives
of your campaign these are all the
objectives that you can set for your ad
and they are organized in awareness in
consideration and conversion or as we
talked earlier the top of the funnel the
middle of the funnel and the bottom of
the funnel important is to remember here
that based on the objective you select
Facebook will give you a certain ad
template and some other features or ad
types may not be relevant for that
particular objective so let's look at
the awareness objectives there are two
type of objectives here brand awareness
objectives and reach objectives now
brand awareness objectives they make
more people aware of your ads if so you
can reach people who are more likely to
pay attention to your ads and increase
the awareness for your brand yep and
then you give it a campaign name now you
may want to go for reach objectives and
with reach objectives you want to show
your ads to the maximum number of people
yep you can also look at the
consideration objectives and there's
quite a few objective
that you can choose from you can look at
traffic where you can send people to
another place like Omer or Facebook like
your website or an app or a messenger
you can look at engagement objectives
where you can reach more people who may
engage with your page or your post you
can look at app installs where you get
people to download your app from the App
Store for instance or video views where
you can raise awareness about your brand
by reaching more people that can watch
your videos you can look into lead
generation where you can reach people
who may fill in a lead form or you can
do specific ads around messages yep way
you promote conversations with people in
messenger to for instance complete the
purchase or answer questions or offer
support we can also look at the
conversion objectives in the conversion
objectives you can look into playing
conversions where you get people to take
valuable actions on your website or your
app or in messenger like adding a
payment or making a purchase yep and you
can use the Facebook pixel or app events
to track and measure these conversions
and we'll come back to that in later
lessons you can also create an objective
around your catalog sales where you can
create ads that automatically show items
from your catalogue and then finally you
can set objectives around store visits
so you can promote multiple business
locations to people who are nearby your
store so lots of things that you can
select when it comes to your your
objectives and then the next thing you
do you set obviously you set a name for
your campaign and by filling in your
campaign name you also need to think
about a strategy that you have for your
naming if you run the alt advertising
campaign on Facebook it doesn't make
that big an impact but if you run lots
of ads you may want to put some sort of
a logic in your naming for your ads so
use profit variables or target February
balls or location variables and then
you're going to decide whether you want
to do with testing of your campaign a
split test yep or an a/b test so you
create two versions of your your ad and
you're going to test one version for
and the second version week 2 and you
you check which ad gives you the best
performance and you can also look at
budget optimization you can set a daily
budget and you can set your campaign bid
strategy yep and there's Advanced
Options here as well so you can set the
scheduling you can set run the ads all
the time or you can run the ads
according a specific schedule and you
can also look at the delivery type so
you can go for a standard delivery for
your ads or in an accelerated delivery
and with a standard delivery you
basically let Facebook decide what the
best delivery schedule is for your ads
or when you click for an accelerated
delivery
you let Facebook spend your buck set as
quickly as possible
now that you've set your campaign
objectives the next thing you're going
to do is to create your ad sets and
there are three elements in your ad set
there is your audience creation
placements and budget and schedule so
let's start with the audience creation
the audience creation is the area where
you basically pick the target market
that you want to reach with your ads and
this is where Facebook is really
powerful and it's also a really cool
area to work with because you can
specify to the minutest detail the
people that you want to target by
location by age or by gender by language
or by interests or the type of
connections that you have with them what
you also see here on the right is an
estimate of the audience size and the
daily reach you look at based upon your
targeting criteria you can also pick a
saved audience and we'll come back to
that in the next lesson where are we
going to look at the different types of
audiences that you can create in
Facebook and that you can use for your
advertising campaigns but let's go into
the basics first so you can select by
location for instance I can say in the
United Kingdom or just give me by city
want to select London yeah and then it
gives me here London England and then I
can also specify everyone in this
location or people who live in this
location people know people that reason
he were in this location or people who
were travelling in this location so this
could work really well for your store to
target people who are nearby or for your
event yep so people that are attending
your event so you can target them with
your advertising as well here you can
pick the H so let's say we're gonna
target men between 18 and 30 years old
and then we're taking the man in London
you see now how our audience eyes has
shrunk to 1 million eight hundred and
then we're going to look at the detailed
targeting we're going to look at
interests or we look at behaviors so one
interest could be football I want man
that are interested in football but I
can also add other elements so I can say
make it Arsenal so I can say do Arsenal
Football Club so I can now target all
the men who are interested in football
and in in Arsenal Football Club so very
likely I'm picking the Arsenal fans here
and I can then target them with my
campaign I can ask suggestions as well
so when you pick the selections then
Facebook will come back to you well okay
maybe you also want any other of these
suggestions so here for instance I can
actually pick football fans yeah and
then again you see how your audience
eyes would would be adjusted based on
the selection that you made you can also
look at your connection so by friends
your Facebook page people who like your
page friends of people who like your
page or you can exclude people who like
your page if you want to approach new
fans so as you can see lots of targeting
options within the within Facebook to
make sure your ad reaches the right
audiences then you're going to the next
section and that is placements there's
two options automatic placements or
you can place to take care of the
placement yourself when you pick all
traumatic placements you basically let
Facebook decide for you what where your
ads should feature and that's the
recommended option there is also the
Edit placements and that will basically
allow you to decide yourself where you
want to place your ads and it's good to
go through this because it shows you the
different options that there are for
your ads you can have it on mobile or on
desktop and then here you see all the
different platforms where you can place
your ads you can placed on Facebook in
all these different areas you can place
your ads on Instagram in the feeds and
in the stories you can also place your
ads in the audience network and the
audience network is a network of
thousands of websites where Facebook
will place your ads so those ads will
not appear on Facebook on Instagram
Instagram but on the network of websites
that Facebook has relationships with and
you can decide which websites you would
like to pick for that and then you can
also place your ass in messenger you can
also specify the different mobile
devices whether it's Android or iOS so
that could work really well if you for
instance you have an iOS app which is
not available Android then here you can
decide where that you will only want to
feature your ads on the iOS and you can
also look at excluding content and
publishers so here you can say don't
show my ads on these web sites or in
these articles for instance once you've
completed this section you're then going
to your budget and schedule the basic
settings are what is your daily budget
or what is your lifetime budget and then
the schedule you can say run my ad set
continuously starting today or set a
start and an end date episode that's
where you can decide how you want to run
your ad at what budget but there are
also advanced options that give you more
options yep so you can decide on your
bit strategy when you are charged so I
only
see here that I can pay by impression
because you want as many people as
possible to see your ad but when you
click for instance traffic that you want
people to drive them to your website you
can then also pay by click yep so
instead of thousand impressions you
would pay when somebody clicks on the
call-to-action button or the link in
your ad you can also decide on your ad
scheduling and also on the delivery type
and we talked about that earlier it can
be standard delivery or accelerated
delivery where Facebook will get your
ads posted and Facebook will run through
your budget as quick as possible so
those are the settings in the ad set and
the next step is that you're going to go
into the ad creation module now that
you've completed your ad set you're
going to burn your focus to the ad
creation and there are four elements in
the earth creation you're looking at the
identity what business are you using to
represent the ads what's the format of
the ad what are the media like the
photos and the videos that you will be
using and what was the text that you
will use in the ad so let's look at this
in a bit more detail in the identity
you're basically going to connect your
ad to one of your Facebook pages or to
an Instagram account so that shows you
then how what business is represented
for the for the ad you're then going to
move to the format selection of the ad
and there are two main formats there is
in single image or video style ad and
there is a carousel style ad where you
can have two or more scrollable images
and thirdly there is also an instant
experience which is a mobile ad but that
includes a landing page that will pop up
when somebody interacts with your your
ad and that's where you can get details
from the customer if they want for
instance a voucher they may enter their
their email detail or their or their
contact details so let's have a look at
the single image video or video ad in a
bit more detail if you select that then
here you see
choose one or more images a video or a
slideshow and that's where you can have
up to six ads with different images and
Facebook will use those ads and if you
select testing with the the ads then
Facebook will test the different ads so
you can check which ad will give me the
best performance there is an interesting
new feature in facebook advertising
where you can turn images into videos
and there's some templates in there as
well so I can show you if I can take a
square template or a vertical template
and the a you see how that would look
like as an ad so it's all about driving
engagement and making your ads visually
more attractive and Facebook has lots of
options for you to make that as easy as
possible so that is your video ad or
your photo ads and then below here by
the way you see the preview of your ads
how it would look like and when we're
going to add text you'll see how that
would work as well I also want to show
you the carousel ads I really like the
carousel ads in the carousel ads you can
add multiple photos in which you can
tell a story in which you can have
multiple products that you could feature
you could also take one big one large
photo that you would chop up in four or
five photos and you would scroll as it
were horizontally through those photos
they work really well so use that as an
as an option if you have like a product
catalog or if you have larger photos
that where that can really enhance the
viewing experience of your ad you can
then add the instant experience we
talked about that as well once you're
happy with the style of the ad and you
uploaded your photos and let's say we're
going for the single image video ads you
would then see how the ad would look and
then you're going to enter your text
there and that is a skill in itself and
in this course you will find various
sections where we'll give you tips about
a type of text that you may want to
include you got to keep it simple you
got to make it very powerful you need to
have clear
two actions people really like free star
flight promotions so amplify that in the
text of your ad other good thing that
people do in the text of the ads is use
referrals for instance let your
customers talk about how good you have
good job products then you can add
various components so you can have
background colors you can have the
website URL and there are some advanced
options as well that you have here you
can have different parameters for your
for your URL which is basically it will
be added to the website URL which
basically means that you could track the
the URL in the your Google Analytics as
well and then you can set up conversion
tracking for your ad as well and we'll
talk about that in more detail in the
next lesson now here you see a very
important aspect of the the answer when
you submit your ad Facebook will review
your ads and will check the the text
will check the image will check the
landing page and if he ad is not good
than and does not comply with the rules
and regulations then Facebook will not
approve your ad and you will get a
message and then you will have to to
change the ads one of the most important
rules in the ad is the 20% textual so
your image may not have more than 20%
stake and here you see that my ad may
reach slightly lower because then there
may be a little bit too much text of the
ad Facebook will not outrightly decline
your ad but it will basically give you a
slightly lower reach if your ad has too
much text and there's more about this
later in the course so then basically
when you're ready you click confirm and
then your ad will go up will be uploaded
to Facebook and then of course Facebook
wants the money so you then need to
enter if you haven't done that yet
you will have to enter your credit or
debit card information so facebook can
take payment
Facebook add images and text Facebook
has a really nice add images cheat sheet
in summary it's all about being
interesting with your image being
focused exciting consistent and fresh
and most important of all make sure
there is a connection between the image
and the message here are a few more tips
on using images in your ads to highlight
a few show people use faces of people
make sure your images are high rest keep
it simple use one call-to-action people
love free stuff use location related
graphics use of psychology of color now
let's expand on this psychology of color
here are some thoughts about the
psychology of color try using these in
your ads when you want people to buy use
red if you want to grab attention use
yellow if you want to be seen as a
trusted partner use blue and so on lots
of ideas for your ads the final section
in your ad creation is the ad texts here
you will also get an ad preview on the
different devices you can even set a
background color for your text in the
Advanced Options you can set tracking
parameters and conversion tracking via
the Facebook pixel Facebook also created
an ad copy cheat sheet to highlight a
few of them tie your text to the visual
speak to your audience keep it short
mention price when relevant and include
a time frame when relevant Facebook @
review process so up till here we looked
at ad setting objectives for your
campaign targeting the right people
deciding on budget and placement and
created the ads we're ready to run the
campaign now hold on not yet next
Facebook has to approve the ads it will
look at the text the image and even the
landing page and it will evaluate all
this it will check if the ad complies
with Facebook's advertising policies if
the text is correct and not too dominant
and if the ad is consistent with the
landing page from a message
point of view usually Facebook approves
your ad within 24 hours if it's not
approved Facebook will tell you what's
wrong with it and you have to change the
ad accordingly you can then submit it
again for approval there's always been a
lot of buzz around Facebook's 20% text
rule it basically means that your ad
can't have more than 20% text in it here
you see where you find the text in your
ads there's the body text and there can
be text in the image these are the
elements that Facebook will check it's
not a rule set in stone but it's a good
guideline the general principle is that
ads with less than 20% text tend to
perform better here are some reasons why
your ads may not pass there's too much
text in the image you're mentioning
Facebook in the ads or you're breaking
the advertising policies like age
restriction or alcohol ads or prohibited
subjects like gambling there are two
ways of targeting people for your ads in
facebook you can do broad targeting and
specific targeting with broad targeting
you let it all up to Facebook and the
Facebook's delivery system will make
sure that your ads will go to the ideal
audience when you want to be in control
you can go for specific targeting you
can do this by giving Facebook a set of
targeting parameters to find the best
people to show your ads to broad
targeting would be ideal for awareness
campaigns where you target generically
with a very broad geographic area
specific targeting can work very well
for local businesses when you go to the
audience section in the ad set creation
of ad manager you will first see your
broad targeting options you can start
with selecting an existing or a saved
audience and more about this later but
if you start from scratch you begin with
selecting the location age range gender
and language on the right you will see
the audience size this is based on your
targeting criteria that you've just
entered
and Facebook market data it can also be
influenced by the budget you set note
that you can include multiple locations
if you scroll down you will go to the
specific targeting section where you can
define your audience by interests or
behaviors this is where you will find
the real power of Facebook advertising
this is where you can zoom in on micro
communities but before I go into showing
you how to select interests or behaviors
I want to introduce you to Facebook
audiences Facebook audiences enable you
to create even more specific audiences
based on a variety of criteria you can
go to Facebook audiences when you click
on the hamburger menu at the top left of
your ad manager underneath the assets
header you will see audiences and when
you click on this it will take you to
your audience manager once you're in the
audience section you can see that you
can create an audience and you see a
list of different audiences you've
created earlier you can also see that
when you click on create audience you
can create three different type of
audiences the three audiences you can
create in audience manager are custom
audiences look-alike audiences and saved
audiences custom audiences can be
created from lists that you already have
like your email lists they can also be
created from people visiting your
website or people engaging with your
mobile app look-alike audiences can be
created based on a specific customer
audience Facebook will look at people
with similar characteristics and turn
them into a look-alike audience saved
audiences allow you to specify your own
segmentation and behavior criteria you
can save these and reuse these audiences
for different ad campaigns
Facebook has a very powerful tool that
can help you manage your audiences in
the ad manager if you click on audiences
under the assets it takes you to the
audience manager and on this screen you
see a brand new feature that you can
include lifetime value of your clients
in creating a custom audience yeah or
you can go into creating the three
audiences or the three audience types
that Facebook lets you create you can
create a custom audience look-alike
audience or a saved audience so let's
have a look at this in a bit more detail
to go through the process of including
your lifetime value of your customer you
click here on the get started and then
you go through a whole process of adding
the customer file choosing the customer
value then you can met the data from
your customer file you can upload and
create a look-alike audience so that is
one aspect of the custom audience
creation what I want to show you is the
three main areas where you can create
audiences that is the custom audience to
look-alike audience and the safety
audience so let's start with the custom
audience these are the people that have
already shown an interesting you so they
are an ideal source to target and they
can be brought into Facebook into two
ways you can either upload customer data
through a file like a CSV file or you
can capture people's data when they take
a specific action like visiting your
website opening your app or even
visiting your your store so there's
different ways that you can create these
custom audiences so the most simple one
is to create an audience by uploading
your customer data in an Excel
spreadsheet and that could include email
details of your clients Facebook will
then check if these customers use this
email to create their Facebook account
and if that's the case they will be put
in
a custom audience so that's one area so
the next area is to create an audience
through capturing people who visit your
website now we call this retargeting and
in facebook terms this is also called
pixel advertising this means that when
somebody visits a particular page on
your website you can capture that
person's detail in a custom audience and
then target that person with an ad for
example if somebody visits a product
page on your website and put a product
in the shopping cart and then decides to
not buy the product and leaves your
website you can then target him on the
next day with an ad to remind him or her
about a product that they wanted to buy
yesterday technically this is very easy
to set up Facebook will give you a
specific piece of HTML code and we call
this the pixel code and you can add that
code to the HTML on the web page that
you want to use for this it's like you
add a pixel to the page that will be
activated when somebody visits that
space and that's why we call this pixel
advertising so you would give the pixel
name you would give the URL of the
website or the web page and then you
basically create the pixel pixel is
there created and then you can install
the pixel on your website and when you
click on install the pixel you see three
different ways that you can use this
pixel you can connect it through a
third-party platform like Magento or
Shopify or Google tag manager you could
take the code and install the pixel code
yourself or you can email the
instructions of how to install the pixel
code to your your web developer to show
you what the pixel code looks like
very straightforward here you see the
code you would copy that code and then
you would paste that in between the
header tags on your on the web page that
you want to activate the pixel for so
that's how you would create a custom
audience for people that are visiting
your your website now there's other
areas as well there is
activity yeah in app activity you can
use the same concept of pixel targeting
BA based on activity on your mobile app
but to do this you need to set up an
epithet which we will discuss in the
next lesson you can also target people
with offline activity like visiting your
store and again you need to set up an
event for that which we will discuss in
the next lesson and you can also create
a list of people who engaged with your
content for instance people that watch
the video filled in a lead form had a
full screen experience and a look on
your Facebook page or looked at your
Instagram business profile or have
interacted with an event that you had on
Facebook and again these are all people
that you can target and then as soon as
they complete one of these sections you
can then put them in a custom audience
so that is the custom audience
segmentation that you can do the next
audience that you can create is a
look-alike audience when you create a
look-alike audience you take an existing
audience that you've created and then
you're going to add a different location
and you can estimate the audience size
as well and then Facebook will create a
similar audience but based on the
different location and maybe with
slightly different segmentation criteria
yes so this works really well if you
want to run for instance campaigns in
cities in your in your country then you
can create you create one segmentation
criteria or various segmentation
criteria but you can change two
locations and replicate the audience by
creating different look-alike audiences
and then the third or the unit stage you
can create is a saved audience in the
saved audience you recognize this screen
it is a similar screen that we had with
the treu with the standard Facebook ad
creation when we were in the ad set and
we looked at the segmentation of your
audience for your ad so you can pick an
existing audience you can change the
location
you can look at age gender at languages
and then here you have your detailed
targeting and that is similar targeting
capabilities like we've seen in the ad
set creation but the power of um using
it here is that you can save the
audience and that you can reuse that
audience for different ad campaigns once
you've created your audiences and you go
back to your audience manager you will
see that you've got a list of the
audiences that you've created and that
has the name it has to type it has the
size and whether the list is available
or not
so now you can select them for specific
ad campaigns and you can edit and
duplicate them and save audiences are
very useful they will save you time in
the ad set creation and reduce errors in
your targeting and they're also easy to
change how they come in handy when you
want to test and experiment your ad
delivery with different audiences but
bear in mind that size of the audience
is very important because when the
audience is too small Facebook cannot
work with it so Facebook prefers a
minimum audience size of 2,000 people
Facebook analytics there are limitations
in the reports you are getting in the
Facebook Ads manager they are limited to
the ad campaigns and the conversion
events you've created is only shows you
the results once the campaign has gone
live and it certainly won't give you
analytics in relation to your Facebook
page or the customer journey to bypass
this problem many marketers use Google
Analytics particularly for getting
insights on the sales funnel and the
customer journey
but the problem with Google Analytics is
that it doesn't track the Facebook pixel
Facebook has recognized this and
introduced Facebook analytics it's the
Facebook version of Google Analytics and
it brings together all data from organic
and paid marketing activities on
Facebook you can access Facebook
analytics through the ad manager it will
give you a Google Analytics style
dashboard summarizing your organic and
paid marketing activities on the Left
you have a menu of options to
from Facebook analytics could be a
two-day course in itself there are so
many excellent features in it it allows
you to analyze how people move through
the sales funnel by measuring actions on
your page your app your website you can
analyze how people use your products
over time you can create new audiences
based on audience analysis in the
percentiles section and you can analyze
customer lifetime value by tracking what
customers spent over time hi there if
you liked this video subscribe to the
simple learn YouTube channel and click
here to watch similar videos turner up
and get certified click here